Celtic verses Rangers one of the most
divisive fixtures in world football and
one of the most heavily policed this
meeting last month passed with no
arrests despite an ever-present
simmering aggression as is the case any
time these teams meet police say good
planning and use of intelligence is the
reason but the use of police informants
in Scottish football has been criticized
one Celtic supporters group believes it
is more suited to serious crime than
football fans there is a culture and say
the Police Service of Scotland which
treats fans and furnitures and football
has been visit a public court that I
should it's about lemon alley it's a bit
public order and that sees something
about that attitude to came the people
that attend football there's Celtic
Rangers is more than just a football
rivalry though it's also still seen by
many as a clash of cultural and
religious identities tackling
sectarianism has been the focus of
policing but a new review he's asking if
the police have gone too far
police admitted failings following a
crush before a match celtic park a
police log of the instant appeared to
show a focus on the singing of offensive
songs the sheer number of people
funneling down this passageway before
the last Old Firm derby here when some
fans felt they had to climb this wall to
escape the crush some even sustaining
injuries as they toppled into the
graveyard at the other side it's led to
allegations that police did not
intervene soon enough the review will
assess not only the crush but policing
of football across Scotland those in
charge of ensuring public safety defend
their techniques regardless of whether
it's football violence disorder serious
organized crime are occurring to
terrorism I believe that the public
would expect us to try and gather
intelligence from any source that we can
and potentially that would involve
involve going to speak to people who we
think are on the periphery of the the
organised violence it does a car and
football gear really the offensive
behavior in football acts
created new criminal offenses concerning
sectarian behavior at football matches
it was repealed last year after
widespread condemnation but the problem
of how to police football in Scotland
remains there's been an anxiety picking
up in the 60s and right through the 70s
and 80s that the policing of football
fans and by that what is actually meant
his young working-class main has been
problematic for of the game itself and
for the police and so you're left with
this sense of a cleaner disconnect
between what the mainstream of society
believes behavior should be and what
young men believe going out in a day out
to support the club means as in England
football in Scotland is increasingly
saying what's the policing which has
helped create that safety is subject to
political pressures unknown
south-of-the-border
Martha Kellner sky- Scotland